for years Brady's come over here and
we've talked about Klein violence in the
mathematics of one-sided services and
we've talked about making them but we've
never actually made a Klein bottle today
in my garden is a Klein bottle but a
Klein bottle maker but the Klein bottle
maker Lucas Clark from Simon Fraser
University
and welcome to Oakland welcome to
Berkeley Welcome to California Lucas oh
thank you for having me
[Music]
all right let's start off with a little
bit of Fire
get that fire going we'll add a little
auction so starting off in the beginning
like yeah this is cold fire so when I
say cold fire there's only about 20
percent oxygen in the air yeah the rest
of it about nitrogen so all that orange
you see there that's actually just
carbon all the fuel that's in the line
that hasn't really fully combusted yet
and as it's going through it's getting
hot and it's getting bright but it's not
burning off
now if I want to melt some glass with
that that's not going to do anything so
we started adding a little bit of oxygen
oxygen from our tank over there we are
piling that in
now we're start cooking
now that that's a flame that's we're
getting a nice balanced mixture of the
gases and the oxygen everything's
burning together beautifully now from
that we're going to take some broad
stock we're going to take some tubes
there's hundreds of types of glass the
one that I'm particularly fond with has
a little pinch of boron in it
creates this beautiful type of glass
called borosilicate many of you might
know it as Pyrex Pirates it's a brand
name but Boris it's beautiful it's
coefficient of expansion the rated it's
expands and we start piling in the
energy
Ah that's much lower so if I was to do
it with like a coke bottle or if I was
to do it with a paint a window or a
window paint something like that the
glass would just start exploding and
popping all over the place but
borosilicate oh this stuff is beauty it
just absorbs the heat it takes it and it
shifts it and it's all quite happy oh
beautiful so we just want to pull this
close
[Music]
so we're gonna blow a bottle
starts off as a bubble
now I want to add a little handle it so
I can shape the body of the climb up
so you notice I'm turning always always
turning
as we're heating the glass all that
energy is getting piled in
but as it's going in the gravity that's
always acting on the glass
so if I was to stop
drops down mix things off guilt it
[Music]
but now I want to make all those little
seals on the inside nice and smooth
just like a tree
or an I-beam all of its strength is on
its surface now we want to add a little
shape we'll add a little form
glass going there's really only three
fundamental actions that you can do you
can constrict it
and blow it
and bend it
[Music]
I'm going to cut this by this heating
locally
and then the force the flame and the
surface tension the glass
[Music]
[Music]
this time around I'm going to do it
concentrically around the edge
oh you got hey we got one hole we're
back to a hole so it like closed off on
my side open on the others we got one
hole now we got to close it off there so
we're gonna bring it back together to be
how many holes
[Music]
ah yes sing for me
for me
I'm gonna come in
get a little Puff
or get a little twist open it up
all right we'll be all excited around
and around right on that surface right
on the top try and keep it nice and
balanced and even do a little Puff
okay so we're starting to see some of
that red coming off we're starting to
see going in
we're in a few different
so we preheated thing
in a sec
all right come in
I'm gonna start to pop
I'm gonna blow this out
[Music]
gather it up and slowly
as it comes together
we're gonna make contact with the out or
the two lips together I'm gonna make
this known as the ring seal it's a
little back nice bath fire
doesn't crack on me but it might who
care
and I'm just gonna start working that in
and we're gonna take a second to get rid
of all those little curved edges
remember to breathe
pop that up
again with our little reamer and we just
kind of push it where we'd like it just
a gentle nut
I'm currently
I don't know how many holes do we have
foreign
[Music]
heat it up bend it round
to work blowing bubbles
turn around
[Music]
[Music]
everybody else let's just give it a
little tap
you know
bring out a little bit of that heat and
we're gonna flash we're going to heat it
up nice smooth and apparent
oh yeah or even the bottle itself it's
tied around on all these ends
[Music]
here's some Talent moves no I'm gonna
grab it I'm just gonna pull it into
place
and here's the uh surface tension and
the grouty to pull all that out and I
can smooth it in a bit and blend it
around
just Glide it along my breath thick
glass and hold on to the heat the
longest
and as you blow on it
stretches the glass
that allows it to move wow
foreign
game I'm gonna wait for this to cool off
so I can just grab with my hand
and then I'll uh work on the other side
probably keep this on a
yeah let's see if we can find that
Center about now Cliff you must have
seen quite a few thousand climb bottles
in your time
just watching the birth of a climb
bottle still excite you or have you seen
it excite me pretty
pretty it's hot glass it's more than
that it's just
somebody whose craft is built into his
fingers to to to hang around Lucas is
just a joy there it is it's the real
deal
handmade
[Music]
oh look at that
hey there if you like Puzzles problems
or just interactive mathematical stuff
then check out brilliant first up here's
an easy one
how much of this pattern is colored
yellow
maybe this will help your thinking but
now how much of this square is shaded
blue hmm
want something else
let's go into the courses here we are
how about these hat problems
hat problems are like a whole thing in
mathematics you know
and they've got loads of them here on
brilliant in fact brilliant is chock
full of stuff like this that's going to
give your brain an entertaining workout
make you smarter if you haven't signed
up already why not do it today number
five viewers get a 20 discount on their
subscription and if you have signed up
well that's okay why not give brilliant
as a gift perfect for the Learner in
your life who already has everything go
to brilliant.org number file for more
information or click the link under this
video thanks brilliant for supporting
number five
well the way I make these
the answer is well sort of yes you can
fill a Klein bottle
with water which money do you want
so I say
I don't know 100 bucks
he reaches into his pocket and starts
counting out twenty dollar bills